of the four Bell states she
would like to share with Bob, and she has the freedom to choose by acting on her qubit alone
and that's a pretty interesting
aspect of entanglement.
Alice then sends her qubit
to Bob, at this point, Bob holds one of the four Bell states and he just needs to
figure out which one it is
to recover the bits.
And we can check that
indeed a controlled NOT gate followed by a Hadamard gate
as we have in the diagram does the right thing.
I won't go through them in detail, but if you choose to do that, you'll find that the effect is
as you see here in the table.
One way to check that
is simply to compute. Alternatively, we can recognize that we actually already
went through this in reverse
in the previous lesson. In the previous lesson we
had the Hadamard gate first and the controlled NOT gate second
and we saw that that circuit
mapped standard basis states to Bell states with a pesky
minus sign in one of the cases.
When we reverse the order of the gates and we consider the fact
that both of these two gates are their own inverses,
what we get is the inverse,
and so what we have in this
case is the action goes in the opposite direction
and the minus sign can choose whichever
side it wants to be on,
but otherwise, it's where it belongs, and at this point it's
immediate that the measurement reveals the correct values,
the minus sign here doesn't bother us because one appears with
probability one in this case, and that's all there is to the analysis.
In a nutshell, Alice picks a Bell state and Bob figures out which one it is.
Just a couple of brief remarks
about superdense coding before we move on; first, we should acknowledge
that superdense coding
is probably not likely
to be useful or practical in any sense as a means to
transmit classical information.
Classical communication
is very inexpensive and physically sending Qubits is challenging to say the least,
and so long as that's the case, we wouldn't expect any
practical advantage at all to come from superdense coding.
But just because it isn't
likely to be practical doesn't mean that superdense
coding is not interesting.
It's very interesting in fact, for one, the underlying idea is
really quite fundamental,
and when I refer to the underlying idea, I mean the idea that if Alice
shares a Bell state with Bob,
then she can choose to change that state to any other Bell state that
she chooses all by herself, she doesn't need Bob's
help at all to do that.
This is a specific example
that concerns the Bell states, but there's a more general underlying idea that concerns the freedom that one player
has to transform an entangled state that's shared with another player, and understanding exactly
what that freedom is
is an important step in understanding quantum information and we'll see exactly how to describe that freedom in simple
and elegant terms In the
third unit of the series.
Superdense coding also
provides a concrete example of what you can do with entanglement, which is to allow two classical
bits to be transmitted
by sending a single qubit. As I already mentioned, this
is provably not possible by Holevo's theorem without entanglement.
We can also consider teleportation and superdense coding together, and we see that they
establish an equivalence
between one qubit of quantum communication and two bits of classical communication.
As long as you're willing
to spend one e-bit, you can effectively
convert one to the other.
Teleportation allows for the
communication of one qubit using two classical bits of communication and superdense coding goes the other way
and allows two classical
bits of communication using one qubit of quantum communication.
Without spending the e-bit, however, you cannot transform
either one into the other, it's entanglement that
makes this possible.
The third and final example
that we'll cover in this lesson is not a protocol but a
game known as the CHSH game.
When we talk about a game in this context, we're not talking about something that's meant to be
played for fun or sport,
but rather a mathematical abstraction in the sense of game theory for instance.
Mathematical abstractions of games are very commonly studied in
economics and computer science, for instance, and there's
quite a lot of value
to be found in the abstraction, so games are not all fun
in games as it turns out,
although it is fun to think about them.
In this particular case, what we have is essentially
a thought experiment that can be described in a
pretty intuitive way as a game.
The letters CHSH refer to the authors, John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony, and Richard Holt of a 1969
paper where the example
was first described. They didn't describe
it as a game, in fact, and it's pretty common
to refer to this example
not as the CHSH game, but
rather as the CHSH inequality.
For a computer scientist like me, however, it's just very natural
to describe it as a game.
I've already suggested that
mathematical abstractions of games are both important and useful and there are many different
categories of games